da dachten wir doch glatt gerade nach
den feiertagen würde uns die pandemie
fest im griff halten
jetzt stellt sich heraus es ist vielmehr
wahlkampf in deutschland wenn schon
schlecht über das virus gestritten
werden kann dann umso besser über die in
verteilung beim lockdown bleibt erstmal
fast alles von alten mindestens bis ende
januar lockt in deutschland kein ende in
sicht jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
die maßnahmen die behördlich geschlossen
haben sind einschneidend sie sind nicht
nur die fortsetzung dessen was wir vor
weihnachten getan haben sondern sie sind
angesichts der lage härter
gerade was kontakt beschränkungen
anbelangt zum teil auf was in hotspots
bewegungsmöglichkeiten anbelangt so weit
die bundeskanzlerin nach dem gespräch
mit den ministerpräsidenten heute in
berlin herzlich willkommen bei uns meine
gäste zunächst hier im studio kristina
dunz ist bei uns hauptstadtkorrespondent
in beim redaktions netzwerk deutschland
nd das ist ein zeitungsverbund für den
sie hier aus der hauptstadt berichten
robert diese ist leiter der fritz
hasenschule in berlin-britz das ist die
älteste staatliche gemeinschaftsschule
in deutschland also von der grundschule
von den abc schützen bis zum abitur
alles unter einem dach zugeschaltet ist
uns professor andreas radbruch andreas
radbruch monologe und mitglied der
nationalen akademie der wissenschaften
leopoldina und der virologe martin
stürmer ist bei uns sie leiten ein
biologisches labor in frankfurt am main
und sie waren im vergangenen frühjahr an
kobe 19 stürme was die kanzlerin da
gerade gesagt hat also nur noch 15
kilometer weg vom wohnort sobald im
stadt oder landkreis wo man wohnt 200
neuen infektionen auf 100000 einwohner
in einer woche und es darf auch nur noch
ein treffen mit einer weiteren person
aus dem nicht eigenen haushalt
stattfinden kann der biologe martin
stürmer mit diesem ergebnis der runde im
kanzleramt leben ja es ist zumindest ein
deutliches zeichen dass wir kontakte
weiter reduzieren weil das ist das a und
o wir haben gesehen dass er mit der
bisherigen form nicht wirklich weiter
kommen und unser ziel nicht zeitnah
erreichen werden und letztere variante
das heißt wir dürfen noch mit einer
person uns treffen außerhalb unseres
haushaltes
die finde ich deutlich wirksamer als
jetzt diese 50 kilometer geschichte weil
ich denke da gerade in den großstädten
in ballungszentren sind 15 kilometer
doch deutlich was anderes als zum
beispiel auf dem land aber insgesamt ein
signal das wäre deutlich stärker auf die
bremse treten als bisher
berlin selbst als stadt hat ja
durchmesser von mehr als 15 kilometern
da wird es möglicherweise auch noch
größere probleme bei der durchsetzung
dieser verschärfung geben
herr professor radbruch wie stark
beeinträchtigt denn die verzögerte
anlieferung von impfstoffen die
bekämpfung der pandemie ist das nur eine
vorübergehende beeinträchtigung oder ist
das etwas was dauerhaften schaden
stiftet na ja es geht nicht es geht
nicht sehr schnell
der plan ist offenbar bis zum späten
frühjahr die risiken gruppen durch griff
zu haben
andere länder ein blick über den zaun in
die usa oder großbritannien und
insbesondere israel zeigt ja dass ist
auch schneller geht und natürlich wäre
es gut es möglichst schnell zu schaffen
hier schneller man es schafft desto
früher kann man daran denken die
hygienemaßnahmen in locktow
zurückzufahren
denn das ändert ja wahrscheinlich die
methode sein die die pandemie beenden
wird jedenfalls hoffen bei analogen das
ja stark und so sieht es ja noch ein
daten die uns bisher vorliegenden über
die testung der hilfsstoffe heraus diese
die schulen sollen ja die ersten
profiteure sein wenn es wieder zu
lockerungen kommt dass wir zwar jetzt
erst im februar seien aber dass die
schulen die als profiteure einer
lockerung sehen da haben die
kultusminister gestern stein und bein
geschworen dass das so kommt glauben sie
daran
ich hoffe es
weil für die schüler die jetzt im laub
down sich befinden und über
videokonferenzen und andere digitale
medien von uns mit aufgaben versorgt
wenn ein austausch treten können das
sind also die schüler die das können wo
das funktioniert zuhause für die ist das
erträglich nicht gut aber täglich aber
wir verlieren schüler also wir haben bei
uns im vierten bis sechsten klassen mal
so nah erhebung gemacht wie es
eigentlich außer nach dem ersten
lockdown hat sich das ausgewirkt auf das
lernen der kinder haben festgestellt das
ist tatsächlich bis zu knapp 40 prozent
schüler sind die schneller gelernt haben
als sonst also eine intensive betreuung
von den eltern zu hause hatten die ja
zwangsweise auch zu hause waren
aber wir haben mussten leider auch
feststellen dass 20 prozent also ein
fünfter über 100 schülern deutlich
weniger gelernt haben also habt
deutliche nachteile erlitten haben wir
abgesehen von den ganzen sozialen
problemen die dahinter stecken das
verstärkt sich jetzt auch potenziert
sich das möglicherweise dieses problem
gerade bei diesen 20 prozent haben mit
sicherheit also wir haben deswegen bin
ich gespannt was der berliner senat
morgen oder übermorgen uns an die an den
schulen weitergeben wird weil die frage
ist ist es uns gestattet beispielsweise
einzige gespräche mit schülern in der
schule zu organisieren also einzelne
schüler kommen zu lassen schüler die wir
sonst nicht erreichen also wir alle
schüler die schaffen es nicht mehr
wieder der pubertierende kinder hatte
oder hat der weiß zu solchen zeiten die
stehen die verkürzung auf also fast ein
jahr und diese schüler erreichen wir
also über videokonferenzen nicht es gibt
eine gruppe von schülern die erreicht
mir überhaupt nicht ja und da so eine
maßnahme zu ergreifen und die
möglichkeit zu bieten ihr kommt in die
schule
wir machen einzige schwäche 1 zu 1 oder
vielleicht ganz kleinen gruppen
ob uns das ermöglicht wird oder nicht
das weiß ich
sich gut auf die schulen die muss man ja
immer im blick haben hat die politik ja
auch das war heute das überraschende das
ist doch relativ drastische maßnahmen
jetzt weiterhin geben wird und uns für
die groko war das ja ein mops idee
jahresauftakt dass die schuldzuweisungen
in sachen beschaffung von impfstoffen
angeht wenn man sich das jetzt mal
anguckt was sollte den letzten tagen da
hin und her gegen zwischen cdu csu und
spd taugt die pandemie als
wahlkampfthema
die pandemie ganz sicher nicht und ich
finde es ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
überraschend dass die spd derart scharf
jetzt mit bundesgesundheitsministerin
sparen umgegangen ist im streit um die
beschaffung der impfdosen ausreichenden
dosen sie haben einen punkt schreiben
also stimmt man hätte deutschland hätte
vielleicht mehr dosen von bayer pfizer
bestellen können also von biontech
bestellen können als die eu versorgt war
und als dieses gemeinschaftsgefühl
erreicht worden war dass man gemeinsam
vorgeht und gemeinsam bestellt das was
jetzt passiert ist dass der vizekanzler
einen fragenkatalog zusammengestellt und
an den gesundheitsminister schickt im
stile einer im grunde genommen eine
anfrage wie es üblich ist dass
oppositionsfraktionen anfrage an die
regierung stellen die sehr kritisch sind
und auch investigativ erscheinen und so
eine art katalog hat nun der
gesundheitsminister von finanzminister
und vizekanzler bekommt das finde ich
sehr ungewöhnlich und das ist auch aus
meiner sicht ein bisschen billiger
wahlkampf somalia der vizekanzler nicht
richtig informiert bin immer so
genannten pro monat kabinett auch immer
anwesend war wo diese sachen der
besprochen werden wusste eigentlich kann
er den kater fragenkatalog selbst
beantworten das glaube ich nicht
unbedingt weil es sind schon sehr
spezifische fragen
und bei der es um die bestellung geht
wann wusste man um welche möglichkeiten
von beyond eck und wie ist auf
gesundheitsminister ebene da vorgegangen
worden
das ist unberechtigt nachzufragen nur
der stil ist verwundert sehr und ist
meiner ansicht nach unnötig in einer
derart großen krise die das ganze land
zu bewältigen hat wenn es da zu einem
dann doch so einem scharmützel zwischen
den koalitionspartnern kommt stürmer die
entscheidungen die heute getroffen
worden sie in berlin bisher durchaus
angst getrieben dass die kanzlerin ganz
offen zugegeben vor allen dingen hat man
angst dass das gesundheitssystem
stichwort intensivstation kollabiert und
angst auch vor mutationen die
möglicherweise die infektions lage noch
weiter verschärfen sie haben gerade
gesagt dieser 15 kilometer radius um
diese orte die hohe incident ziehen
haben also mehr als 200 pro woche pro
100000 einwohner das bringt gar nicht so
viel
warum ist das so warum glauben sie dass
das möglicherweise neben den mangelnden
überprüfungsmöglichkeiten nicht so
günstig ist aus biologischer sicht ja
ich glaube dass da mehr so ein bisschen
die zum einen die bilder im hinterkopf
stecken die wir haben wochenenden
gesehen haben wo sehr viele
tagesausflüge hier unsere schönen
verschneiten berggipfel besucht haben
und sich mehr oder weniger fast tot
getrampelt haben das ist natürlich auch
wenn es im freien ist haben aus infekt
zu logischer sicht eine katastrophe und
ich denke unter dem eindruck hat man
sicherlich auch versucht da was zu
machen weil 50 kilometer ist schon
relativ viel gerade in großen städten
sind 15 km doch auch eine reichweite wo
ich immer noch genug leute treffe und
insofern denke ich dass das eher eine
nachgeordnete weitere maßnahme ist die
das erste die kontakt beschränkung auf
die eine person außerhalb des haushaltes
unterstützt herr professor radbruch wenn
sie sich jetzt an sehen sie haben gerade
gesagt das ist im prinzip die
voraussetzungen fast die einzige um die
pandemie wirklich zu überwinden wenn sie
sich jetzt unter der voraussetzung es
wird jetzt geimpft es wird auch mehr
geimpft gleichzeitig sind die lockdown
maßnahmen auch erfolgreich ist das eine
kombination die sie auch optimistisch
macht dass man den absehbar
erstens mehr ist und zweitens dann eben
auch diese doch ziemlich starken
einschränkungen inzwischen wieder
zurücknehmen kann ja ich denke zunächst
würde ich sagen dass das ich denke dass
die impfkampagne sich ganz schlecht
eignet als wahlkampfthema denn es geht
ja hier letzten endes darum möglichst
viele todesfälle zu verhindern und
möglichst schnell zu sein es eignet sich
glaube ich auch nicht dazu jetzt
rückwärtsgewandt irgendwelchen leuten
schwarzen peter zuzuschieben
sondern ich hoffe dass das die
diskussion im augenblick über die
schleppenden anfangsphase der
impfkampagne dazu führt dass die
em-kampagne optimiert wird und das
möglichst rasch nach geordert wird bei
den wettbewerbern die tatsächlich
liefern können um sozusagen möglichst
schnell eine durchimpfung zumindestens
der impfwilligen risikogruppen zu
erreichen
und wenn das gelingt so zu sagen dann
hat die pandemie ja ihren schrecken
verloren dann sozusagen ist die
voraussetzung geschaffen dass er
tatsächlich in diesem jahr noch zu einer
situation kommen wo eine immunität eines
größeren bevölkerungsteil werden dem
unität erreicht ist und und man dann
sozusagen die hygienemaßnahmen wieder
zurück fahren kann
das setzt aber voraus dass was passiert
das eben die bevölkerung auch das
akzeptiert was jetzt auch ein ziemlich
starken einschränkungen tatsächlich
erlassen worden ist es dass jetzt so
eine art fluch der bösen tat weil man
eben im november und im oktober
vergangenen jahres nicht das gemacht hat
was man hätte tun müssen nämlich doch
stärker zuzugreifen bei einem harten und
kurzen lockdown ist das sozusagen jetzt
die rechnung die das virus der politik
für die zögerliche haltung präsentiert
ich würde sagen ganz klar es gibt auch
ministerpräsidenten wie den
linkspolitiker bodo ramelow auf
thüringen die das ganz klar jetzt sagen
dass sie es tatsächlich unterschätzt
haben dass sie viel härter schon im
oktober hätten vorgehen können und wenn
ich an die wissenschaftler verweisen
darf die eigentliche seiten monaten
nichts anderes sagen als dass das futter
dieser viren
kontakt ist also wie wir menschen sind
und dass wenn man es wenn die welt so
funktionieren würde dass man sie drei
wochen runterfahren könnte komplett dann
hätte die pandemie keine chance das
können wir nicht das ist klar aber wir
haben uns ja immer stückweise so voran
gehandelt so zu sagen und ich würde
gerne auf einen sache verweisen die
heute in der bundespressekonferenz für
mich sehr eindrücklich war da haben die
kanzlerin und der bayerische
ministerpräsident verein doch ihre sehr
sehr große sorge vor der mutation dieses
virus geäußert und sie haben das nicht
so deutlich ausgesprochen aber
angedeutet wenn das dazu kommt dass also
die viel aggressiveren viren wie es
heißt die jetzt schon bekannten viren
frist und das alles noch viel schneller
verbreiten kann
dann werden wir sehr viel schneller an
die grenzen des gesundheitssystems
stoßen und dann sind viele viele
milliarden verbraucht an
staatsverschuldung ob man dann noch
einmal eine so große kraft aufwenden
kann das alles aufzufangen das ist
fraglich und deswegen die kanzlerin
sprach von einem wettlauf gegen die zeit
ich glaube den haben wir schon im grunde
genommen seit märz aber jetzt hat sie
das nochmal so deutlich gemacht dass
diese verschärfungen eben aus ihrer
sicht und aus sicht der
ministerpräsidenten sein mussten
dann kann man ja auch aus fehlern der
vergangenheit lernen das führte dazu
dass für den bereich der schulen
bedeuten wenn es noch einmal zu einer
pandemiewelle käme oder eines tages zu
einer ganz anderen konnte niemand weiß
ja auch nicht wie weit sich der virus
noch weiter mutiert was da auf uns
zukommen kann
geh da auch für die schulen das was ja
nicht geschehen ist nämlich eine
einheitliche klare linie in allen
bundesländern zu sagen wir haben ein
großes problem ein harter aber kurzer
lockdown das ist nötig und danach sind
wir wieder auf der sicheren seite denn
so hat man sich wie am meisten
eigentlich der bildungspolitik durch
laviert wenn ich jetzt gar nicht könnte
gar nicht sagen wie da eigentlich so die
in wesentlichen diskussionen der letzten
wochen waren so oder so so komplex und
so unübersichtlich waren sie gilt das
auch was jetzt für die politik gilt über
ganz besonders für die bildung und die
schulen ja dann gehe ich auf jeden fall
also wir haben die situation ja gehabt
wenn man es beobachtet hat die
bundesländer sehr unterschiedlich
reagiert haben das gilt auch für den
bildungsbereich
ich sag mal in berlin bin ja nun in
berlin neukölln und
hat man die situation dass
beispielsweise von den schulen pläne
entwickelt wurden wie man hybrid
unterricht machen kann so dass man das
abstandsgebot einhält die masken pflicht
hat und das regelmäßig lüften
das ist schulen untersagt wollen bei
berlin offensichtlich dann auch im
rahmen der der kultusministerkonferenz
dargestellt hat wir machen
präsenzunterricht das gab in berlin
einige schulen die angefangen haben im
hybrid unterricht zu unterrichten
einfach um die infektionszahlen niedrig
zu halten und das aber untersagt waren
lange zeit also auch da meines erachtens
zu ähnlich wir haben nur für thüringen
sagt eine fehleinschätzung wir wissen
jetzt auch dass kinder genauso viele
viren inhalt samen rachen haben wir
erwachsene wenn sie infiziert sind nur
die krankheiten ja aus spricht also wir
sehen es nicht aber offensichtlich
passiert ja in den schulen auch insofern
bin ich sehr froh darüber dass wir jetzt
eine klare entscheidung habe die für
beide gilt und dass wir tatsächlich mit
den schülern über die mittlerweile
eingeübten und abrupten wege weiter
kommunizieren sie weiter unterrichten
können bei allen problemen die das für
die soziale bildung bedeutet also
demokratie und sehen dass man da
versucht hat gerade im bildungsbereich
sich so gegenseitig auszutricksen dieses
erst die schulen seien ja überhaupt
keine hot spots die könnten ja offen
bleiben dann gab es doch eine eine
forschungsergebnis dass auch da
natürlich das ausbrechen kann das
sondern immer versucht hatte immer so
als sei den interessen heraus seine
schäfchen ins trockene zu bringen und
der rest vor allem dann relativ egal
ja das ist politisches geschäft also was
politiker dazu welche handlung bewegt
das mag ich manchmal nicht
nachzuvollziehen ist manchmal so und das
hieß lange zeit auch gerade in berlin
aber auch in anderen bundesländern ja
schulen sind nicht die ansteckung sword
und das stimmt sicherlich in großen
teilen auch aber wir hatten auch in
berlin einige schulen die komplett
geschlossen werden mussten weil es auf
einmal los ging keiner so richtig wusste
warum jetzt eigentlich warum jetzt
gerade an dieser schule
die haben doch alle maßnahmen ein jahr
halten die haben sich auch so verhalten
die sondern leben ja auch
häusern haben kontakt mit vielen anderen
wahrscheinlich auch gar keine
verwunderliche entwicklung hat uns hat
das ja gerade professor radbruch und
stürmer hat das ja gerade gesagt diese
mutation die ja möglicherweise schon in
deutschland unterwegs ist die angeblich
aus dem vereinigten königreich kommt die
es war nicht gefährlicher aber
infektiöser und ansteckender ist was das
müssen wir da eigentlich jetzt
befürchten gerade in bezug auf das
impfen ist das wirklich so dass der
impfstoff das hat ja zumindest bei
wanted glaube ich versichert dass dieser
impfstoff auch diese mutation quasi
abdeckt oder könnte er sich in einigen
wochen herausstellen dass wir neue
impfstoffe brauchen radbruch vielleicht
als es also meine informationen ist es
so dass der impfstoff diese variante
auch abdeckt aber natürlich es ist immer
möglich
das neue varianten auftauchen die von
dem impfstoff nicht abgedeckt werden
dann muss der impfstoff abgeändert
werden was bei diesen neuartigen
impfstoffen relativ schnell passieren
kann also das ist ja der vorteile dieser
neuen technologie dass man die im
stadtarchiv schnell anpassen kann
wichtig erscheint erscheint mir dass man
möglichst schnell diesen möglichst
vielen risikogruppen mitgliedern eine
grundimmunisierung gibt denn das würde
sozusagen schwere krankheitsverläufe bei
diesen patienten verhindern
weniger wichtig scheint es zu sein dass
die zweite impfung genau 21 tage nach
der ersten impfung erfolgt man könnte
diesen zeitraum strecken und was zurzeit
passiert dass ich von den wenigen
impfdosen die verfügbar sind noch die
hälfte zurück gehalten wird um die
erstmals kämpften auch zum zweiten mal
zu ende erscheint erscheint mir nicht
sinnvoll und die deutsche gesellschaft
oli hat heute eine stellungnahme
herausgegeben in der sie empfiehlt die
zweite impfung auch bis zu 60 tage nach
der ersten impfung zu strecken
da sind wir vollkommen d'accord mit
unseren britischen kollegen
ähnliche stellungnahme ausgegeben haben
und dann die die erstmals games mit
einem mit einer weiteren späteren charge
des impfstoffs zu kämpfen um sozusagen
jetzt erstmal bei möglichst vielen
risikopatienten eine grundimmunisierung
herzustellen die schweren verlauf der
krankheit verhindern würde
und wenn das passiert so zu sagen dann
wären sie eben auch zumindest vor sehr
schweren verläufen bei einer erhöhten
infektionsraten geschützt als das heißt
auch von einer neuen variante wie sieht
das der virologe also eigentlich müsste
man ja bisher ist man davon ausgegangen
nach einer erst eine zweitimpfung
innerhalb von drei wochen machen damit
also dieser impfschutz da wirklich auf
dauer auch wirksam ist
jetzt hieß es ja heute auch
möglicherweise bräuchten die infostelle
dann nicht mehr zu haften
für die folgen wenn diese abstände zu
groß würden wenn man sich sozusagen
nicht an die angaben der hersteller hat
hält und auch die europäische
zulassungsbehörde hat ja unter dieser
prämisse die zulassung gemacht gibt es
da probleme wenn man jetzt sagt jeder
erst mal eine dose und irgendwann später
dann die nächste damit sie mit den
impfdosen dahin kommen ja ich sehe das
durchaus problematisch wir haben eine
studienlage die sehr eindeutig gezeigt
hat dass wir eine sehr sehr hohe schutz
davor haben schwer zu erkranken wenn wir
in diesem bestimmten abstand impfen
natürlich ist es so dass im realen leben
diese drei wochen
was die exakt eingehalten werden können
das sind gibt es sicherlich ein
spielraum dass man da ein bisschen nach
hinten gehen kann
ich würde aber davor warnen das zu weit
auszudehnen um dann die ganze logistik
die dahintersteht nicht
durcheinanderzubringen weil denn dann
fehlt fällt doch mal eine chance aus und
plötzlich stehen viele leute da die denn
vielleicht die zweite impfung gar nicht
oder viel zu spät bekommen
insofern würde ich mich immer auf die
studienlage zu ziehen auf die zulassung
zurückziehen und gemäß der zulassung
agieren ich denke dass vielleicht der
ansatz nun effektiver sein wird aus
diesen fläschchen wo
durchaus im überfluss eingekehrt
eingefüllt worden ist er eines meine
sechste dosis rauszuziehen und das über
die zulassungsbehörde abzusichern
weil das würde auch uns deutlich mehr
impfstoff zur verfügung stellen und
meiner meinung nach ist das der
sicherere weg vor uns wenn wir uns die
beschaffungsmaßnahmen noch mal ansehen
die lief ja über die europäische union
gibt es jetzt massive kritik
einerseits das wären der eu bürokratie
nicht richtig gemanagt worden dann hätte
diese geiz ist geil mentalität
vorgeherrscht dass möglichst die kosten
niedrig zu halten
jetzt haben uns die anderen israel usa
großbritannien die impfstoffe
weggeschnappt und wir zweifeln sozusagen
aus dem letzten loch ist das mehr als
nur wahlkampfgetöse ist da wirklich was
falsch gelaufen oder war die
erwartungshaltung einfach zu hoch am
anfang dass sofort alles funktioniert
und dass genügend impfstoff da ist dann
müsste man hier noch fragen wie sollte
ein zu schnell herkommen
ich glaube am anfang stand das bemühen
der kanzlerin während der deutschen
eu-ratspräsidentschaft vor allem europa
zusammenzuhalten in dieser pandemie und
wir erinnern uns an die scharfe kritik
an deutsch-deutschen an die scharfe
kritik an deutschland in der
schuldenkrise in der euro krise in der
flüchtlingskrise vor deutschland immer
vorgeworfen wurde
es drücke und vor allem die kanzlerin
drücke auch gerade finanzschwächeren
ländern so einen deutschen stempel auf
und nun ist deutschland ein ganz anderen
weg gegangen oder einen vorsichtigeren
weg ein solidarischeren weg auch aus den
sehr schlechten erfahrungen aus dem
frühjahr als die diskussion war die
grenzen zuzumachen und der italienische
ministerpräsident in der ard eine
flammenden appell an deutschland
gerichtet hat doch auf italien zu
schauen wo die menschen zu tausenden
gestorben sind und ich selber glaube ich
um die masken auch die dann
zurückgehalten und das ist genau das war
der entscheidende punkt am dank anja die
distel und dass man die grenzen zu macht
es war aber jedenfalls eine abschottung
eine abgrenzung und einbunkern in
deutschland kritisiert worden
das hat das bemühen der bundesregierung
war europa also nicht nur deutschland
zusammenzuhalten sondern auch nach
europa was ja elementar wichtig ist weil
diese pandemie oder keine pandemie an
grenzen haltmacht dass die eu kommission
das brüssel extrem schwerfällig ist
extrem bürokratisch wissen wir aus
vielen vielen anderen bereichen und das
ist leider auch diesmal wieder passiert
es ist alles etwas langsamer alles etwas
vorsichtiger sicherlich nicht schlechter
im inhalt aber dann eben nicht mit dem
wunsch auf den nun alle gewartet haben
ich glaube trotzdem dass diese
erwartungshaltung das ist sehr schnell
alles sehr schnell gehen kann und muss
zu hoch ist
sie werden das die experten werden das
besser erklären können aber die normale
entwicklung eines impfstoffs dauert ja
noch eigentlich jahre
nun ist das ganze in neun monaten
passiert und das ist da sehr ruckelt und
dass es verteilungskämpfe gibt und dass
die eu viel geschickter hätte sein
können und dass man mehr dosen bestellen
hätte können wo man millionen von
schulden aufnimmt um die wirtschaft zu
retten hätte man im nachhinein sagen
können dann geben wir nicht nur sieben
milliarden sondern 70 milliarden aus
oder es spielt ja fast alles gar keine
rolle mehr
um sich das zu sichern aber ich finde
sehr gut was herr professor radbruch
gesagt hat fehler benennen analysieren
das nächste mal besser machen aber wenn
wir jetzt die ganze zeit immer darum
kreisen was alles schief gegangen ist
steht so ein riesenberg den wir
bewältigen müssen vor uns und dann würde
ich lieber versuchen konkret diese
fehler das nächste mal zu vermeiden und
jetzt alles an die front zu werfen so
viel wie möglich an impfdosen zu
bekommen und zum beispiel für das impfen
zu werben denn es gibt ja hohe
prozentzahlen an pflegern
krankenschwestern selbst unter ärzten
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen wir
bräuchten also vorbilder die vorangehen
vielleicht auch ab von der einsortierung
erst die über 80-jährige risiko sondern
dass wir leute die vorbilder sind das
die sich zuerst hinten und dass man das
ja dafür wirbt buch vielleicht ansehen
die frage noch mal was jetzt traut uns
gesagt hat einen riesenberg an problemen
diesen impfstoff zur in dieser kurzen
zeit rasend schnell
zu entwickeln auch wirksam zu entwickeln
dass er auch wirklich sinn macht die
menschen zu impfen um den lock down zu
überwinden war da die erwartungshaltung
einfach viel zu hoch in der politik aber
auch in der gesellschaft dass das eben
schnell geht und das praktisch jetzt
anfang januar jeder der sich impfen
lassen will auch impfen lassen kann
naja ich weiß nicht ob es so extrem war
aber ich finde das eine enorme
erfolgsgeschichte das nicht nur ein
wettbewerber sondern mehrere
wettbewerber dass in zeiten unter von
unter einem jahr schaffen den impfstoff
zu entwickeln das ging ja das geht ja
meistens relativ schnell aber ihn dann
auch noch klinisch zu testen
da müssen sie ja zehntausende von
menschen impfen beziehungsweise mit
einem placebo behandelt und dann die
infektionsraten vergleichen und das
alles über den sommer wo die
infektionsraten jahren nicht gar nicht
so hoch waren also eine riesige
herausforderung in der klinischen
testung und dass das nicht nur eine
sondern mehrere wettbewerber geschafft
haben zeigt doch wie entwickelt die
technologie ist und inzwischen und was
sie leisten kann dass wir jetzt
sozusagen am anfang etwas wie soll ich
sagen stottern sozusagen nicht gleich
millionen ja millionen von impfdosen
aber hunderte von millionen von
impfdosen haben um alle sofort das ist
ja selbstverständlich und klar
auf der anderen seite ist es so wenn man
unternehmer mäßig denkt und sagt wir
haben sechs kandidaten die es vielleicht
schaffen können und man ordert von jedem
so viel dass wenn nur einer davon durch
die ziellinie geht wenn man genug im
material hat um die gesamte bevölkerung
zu impfen
das wären bei 440 millionen einwohner in
der europäischen union wenn man 70
prozent empfinden also über 300
millionen personen die man zweimal
impfen muss dann hätte man also
möglichst schnell sozusagen 600
millionen impfdosen haben müssen
von bayern hat nur 300 millionen
bestellt werden bei den usa mit 330
millionen einwohnern
im 500 millionen dosen bestellt worden
so dass sich 70 prozent der bevölkerung
zweimal geimpft fragen jetzt muss ich
sagen dass die usa sind ja ein start
während die europäische union besteht
aus 27 souverän starten die natürlich
auch eigene interessen da haben sie
haben ja das verteidigungs- und
bestellmanagement kritisiert der
deutschen regierung ja ich denke ich
denke das ist es ist sicherlich in der
vergangenheit denke ich mal schief
gelaufen dass man eben nicht so gedacht
hat dass wenn auch nur ein wettbewerber
durch kommt man auf der sicheren seite
ist
was finanziell sozusagen muss man sagen
dass die eu zunächst mal gedeckelt war
bei 2,7 milliarden euro
beschaffungskosten
während die usa schon im sommer zwölf
milliarden euro dafür ausgegeben habe
und angesichts der summe von 750
milliarden euro für die
wirtschaftshilfen die nötig werden ist
dieser betrag von 2,7 millionen auf 3
milliarden euro
verschwindend gering das also einmal so
dass ich am falschen ende gespart
stürmer ich würde gerne noch als andere
auf etwas das ist jetzt vorbei aus
meiner sicht und jetzt sollte man
eigentlich sehen wie man wie man weiter
kommt und wie man jetzt ist schaffen
kann möglichst schnell möglichst viele
impfungen zu schaffen denn dann
tatsächlich zählt ja jeder tag den ein
risikopatient spil games wird und
einfach tun es schon jetzt gerade schon
angesprochen worden ist ein aspekt ist
interessant in hat glaube ich heute der
bayerische ministerpräsident auch noch
mal erwähnt die frage nämlich dass ich
zum beispiel in altenheimen gerade viele
pfleger und viele ärzte gar nicht impfen
lassen wollen also dort wo ja besonders
das virus besonders grassiert auch mit
verheerenden folgen grassiert da haben
sie eine idee warum das größte das
offenbar nicht nur in bayern so das hat
man aus verschiedenen ecken deutschlands
gehört warum ausgehängt bei dieser
gruppe von menschen die ja viel mit
medizinischen fragen mit alten menschen
mit krone gefährdet zu tun haben eine
solche skepsis sagen wir mal vorsichtig
halber eine solche impfung skeptisch
skepsis herrscht ja das ist eine sehr
gute frage die begegnet mir nicht nur
jetzt zuge von von kogit 19 sondern die
habe ich auch in der vergangenheit schon
schon immer wieder beobachten können
wenn es um die klassische
influenza-impfung geht im
gesundheitssystem
wenn es um empathie des b impfung geht
alles geschichten ja masern mumps röteln
windpocken in kinderkliniken ist überall
immer so eine skepsis ich kann sie
persönlich nicht nachvollziehen weil ich
bin ein absoluter fan von impfungen
überall wo eine impfung angeboten wird
bin ich mit einer der ersten der hurra
schreit ich würde das auch hier tun wenn
sie mir angeboten wird wird ich trotz
meiner durchgemacht infektion noch mal
zuschlagen
ich kann es leider nicht gute
beantworten warum es dabei bei den
vielen kolleginnen und kollegen so eine
zurückhaltung und eher skepsis gibt weil
ich finde auch gerade in der position
hat man nicht nur verantwortung für sich
selber für seine eigene gesundheit
sondern eben genau auch für die
mitmenschen und mit denen man zu tun hat
alltäglich war möglicherweise fake news
in den sozialen netzwerken auch ganze
arbeit geleistet dass das zur
verunsicherung beiträgt denn die zahl
derjenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
man liegt ja bei 20 bis 25 prozent noch
mal die gleiche zahl will erst mal
abwarten
nur 50 prozent sagen ja ich will mich
auf jeden fall impfen lassen ist das
auch was diese diskussion und ins
gegnern und crooner leuten angeht da ein
resultat
ich würde sagen es ist ja ganz egal wer
wen verunsichern will man muss sich
einfach nur selber überlegen was das
bedeutet und dass man sich selber
schützen kann und dass wir stimmen es
gerade anders angesprochen hat man
gerade in diesen speziellen berufen
pfleger krankenschwestern ärzte ja sagen
muss dass dass sie dieses risiko dann in
ein ganzes altenheimen mehr einbringen
könnten dann werden wir auch die debatte
haben ob sich bestimmte berufszweige
vielleicht sogar pflicht im müssen wenn
sie dann wieder in ein heim gehen wollen
und dort arbeiten wollen die heimleitung
der altenheime sagen nur wenn wir das
zur pflicht machen oder wenn wir solchen
pflegern
und schwestern sagen sie dürfen bei uns
nicht mehr arbeiten wenn sie sich nicht
impfen lassen
dann haben sie mal 30 prozent weniger
und damit können sie ihr heim nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten
das ist ein riesiges problem und ich
finde das ist da könnte mich jetzt gar
niemand verunsichern und sagen das ist
teufelszeug oder ganz gefährlich ich
finde da kann man ganz klar darauf sich
sehen und die pandemie sich entwickeln
sie in diese dramatik diese dramatische
entwicklung und dem kann man einfach nur
mit mit einem solchen geschenkte was
eine impfung ist ja begegnen ist kann es
nicht nachvollziehen die sorge dass
unser der schema eine kurze pause machen
und noch mal auf die schulen blicken
sehen wir gerade von den 20 schülern
gesprochen die da regelrecht gefährdet
sind in ihrer entwicklung auch in ihrer
ganzen persönlichen auch beruflichen
entwicklung durch die ganzen defizite
die durch den lock down entstehen wenn
man sich mal ansieht wie die schulen
jetzt auch weil im februar wenn es
wieder losgehen sollen dann mit diesem
stufenplan sich wieder so langsam in
fahrt kommen sollen der
präsenzunterricht ist eine frage der
wechsel unterricht oder hybrid
unterrichtet die klassen geteilt ein
teil zu hause der andere in der schule
kommunizieren da oder eben dann was
jetzt im januar nötig ist eben dieser
fernunterricht ohne persönlichen kontakt
über vater das nicht auch den schulen in
ihrem ganzen management da muss
unterricht geplant werden da müssen
dienste eingeteilt werden ist das sind
da manche schulen vielleicht sogar
überfordert in diesen aufgaben da
ständig zu reagieren auf eine situation
die mit bildung nichts zu tun hat mit
denen will ich die diskussion über den
verschiedenen verbänden innerhalb der
gew oder energie oder so verfolgung mich
mit kollegen unterhalten
dann habe ich nicht den eindruck dass
die schulen überfordert sind die schulen
sind sehr gefordert und die kollegen
arbeiten zum teil an der grenze ihrer
möglichkeiten aber letztendlich werden
die aufgaben momentan bewältigt was ich
mir wünschen würde ist natürlich dass
den schulen mehr eigenverantwortung an
der stelle zugetraut wird weil keine
senator und kein stadtrat weiß wie viele
schüler in welchen räumen wie viel
kinder mit sonderpädagogischem
förderbedarf ich habe also lernen noch
ein geistiger behinderung
oder sonstige ein beeinträchtigungen das
können wir vor ort regeln da können wir
vor ort reparieren wir müssen vor ort
lösungen finden das meinte ich vorhin
auch mit dem hybrid unterricht wenn wir
wieder anfangen im februar und die
zahlen deutlich unter dem im moment
wissen wir ja gar nicht mehr an eine
zahl an die ich mich halten das sind die
todesraten also auch kann man sich
verlassen glaube ich also wir haben
jetzt über 1.130 todesfall am tag gehabt
die anderen zahlen da hat sieht man kann
die zahlen gehen runter da freue ich
mich und denke letzte transfer wieder
losgehen so war ich ergebnis gestern
noch ganz gut so unterwegs hab gedacht
ab nächster woche fangen wir mit theo
ried unterricht erst über 60 klasse an
und dann fangen wir stufenweise mit den
anderen an als ich mir die zahlen jetzt
noch mal angeguckt habe auch in
vorbereitung heute da ist mir noch mal
deutlicher waren was für ne fahrer
endlich vor uns über uns schwebt und
insofern denke ich dass wenn es im
februar wieder losgeht müssen wirklich
die zahlen deutlich runter sein und wir
sollten alle schulen dann auch ganz
schulspezifische organisieren können
also wir haben ja die stufen die haben
sehr von user von der ersten klasse
haben unterschiedliche festlegung
getroffen über die schule kommt werden
wir haben uns regelmäßig getroffen wir
haben den schülern beraten mit den
eltern beraten und haben für die ersten
bis dritten klassen anderer festlegungen
getroffen als für die vierten bis
sechsten systemen und dann für die
abiturstufe weil die natürlich
unterschiedlich verantwortlich sind und
dass auch unterschiedlich vertragen
also schüler die unsere jüngsten erste
bis dritte klasse die dänen aufzuerlegen
was ja auch zum teil versucht wurde eine
maske zu tragen ganz und hat es geht
nicht das funktioniert nicht erst bis
drittklässler zu sagen ihr dürft euch
nicht berühren ihr müsst unbedingt zwei
meter abstand halten das funktioniert
nicht so wie wir uns nächsten der
situation wo der schulschließungen gibt
wo es gar keine alternative zu der
priorität gesundheitsschutz gibt sie
haben vorhin gesagt es gibt ja schüler
die überhaupt keine struktur haben wenn
sie zu hause ja sehen sie sind sich
selbst überlassen wenn jetzt die in der
schul alltag wieder beginnt
welche probleme sehen sie denn auf die
lehrer zu zu kommen die gerade diese
schüler die sozusagen jahren ohne
irgendwelche anleitungen ohne
irgendwelche führung sich selbst
überlassen waren da wieder in einem ja
auch reglementierten schulalltag zu
integrieren
also das ist also unsere kollegen
arbeiten allen teams und es gibt in den
teams verschiedene beratungen
entscheidung wie mit dieser situation
umgegangen werden soll
also wenn wir jetzt hybrid unterricht
machen dürften dann wäre das so dass die
meisten teams diese schüler die wir ja
wissen wo wir wissen wer das es ne sind
häufig kinder die aus armen
verhältnissen kommen wir haben in der
schule
ungefähr 30 prozent kinder die in armut
leben es sind zum teil familien die ganz
viele kinder haben wo dann im die frage
ist wer von denen acht kindern darf denn
nun an den rechner also wenn wir
videokonferenzen oder sowas machen also
da stecken probleme hinter die man die
viele menschen gar nicht nachvollziehen
können und die frage also wie gehen wir
mit diesen kindern um ist tatsächlich zu
gucken wenn der doktor und vorbei sind
wie die wieder in die schule kommen
können wenn wir beispielsweise hybrid
unterricht machen wäre wäre das eine
gruppe von schülern die würden wir
verpflichten jeden tag zu kommen
während andere kinder nur jede alle zwei
wochen kommen würden na also solche
sachen da muss man individuell auf die
einzelnen kinder eingehen es müssten
teile ganz individuelle gespräche
möglichkeiten geben damit die kinder
auch die struktur die die schule bietet
wieder genießen können nutzen können es
ist ja auch so
kinder sagen häufiger schuhe wenn man
die hochschule anspricht sind die
ziemlich satt jetzt haben wir kinder in
einer siebten klasse und schüler am
telefon der dann sagt ich vermisse die
schule und dann anfängt zu lachen und
sagt ich hätte nie geglaubt dass ich das
sage ja also das bedürfnis nach schule
nach sozialer gemeinschaft ist also
immens groß und da geht den kindern ganz
vielen ihrer entwicklung verloren
sie habe davon gesprochen bis wind
später zu ihrem berufsalltag wenn man
nochmal sich ansieht der stürmer was
denn diese maßnahmen den lock dauern
jetzt betreffen diese verschärfungen
das ist ja möglicherweise gerade jetzt
in bezug auf diesen 15 kilometer radius
ja auch eine reaktion auf den ich nenne
es mal rudi tourismus
der letzten tage und wochen die meisten
biologen sagen ja also man muss wirklich
einen harten lockdown durchziehen um das
virus zu besiegen das lässt sich auch
nachvollziehen damit die die werte
einfach zurückgehen auf diese incidents
werte die wir brauchen um das virus zu
kontrollieren die gesundheitsämter
sollen dass sie auch kontrollieren
können
jetzt sind da trotzdem viele leute
ausgebrochen vielleicht aus kleinen
wohnungen mit vielen kindern um sich mal
einfach in der natur zu bewegen
wie geht man mit diesem problem um das
wird ja möglicherweise uns noch länger
betreffen je nachdem wie lang der
lockdown dauert er könnte ja durchaus
bis ostern noch gehen wie soll man da
psychologisch mit oben gehen also die
virologische sicht ist klar aber die
gesellschaftliche die psychologische ist
eine andere
da bin ich ja absolut bei ihnen da muss
man vernünftige lösung finden ich finde
nichts schlimmer als wenn man jetzt
anfängt die eltern mit ihren kindern
einzusperren und den zu verwehren
wirklich sie an die frische luft zu
gehen
er war selber einen siebenjährigen sohn
und ich merke wie froh er ist wenn du
endlich mal wieder irgendwo die beine in
die hand nehmen kann und los flitzen
kann er kann kein fußball spielen darf
kein schwimmen also da müssen wir
lösungen finden da können wir uns
eigentlich nicht starr auf solche solche
regeln zurückziehen
bei aller liebe für den infektionsschutz
der mir auch sehr wichtig ist ich finde
gerade in dem kontext muss man lösungen
finden dass man den familien muss
möglich macht in die freie natur zu
gehen weil das infektionsrisiko wenn man
draußen im wald spazieren geht nicht
jetzt gerade sich alle auf den feldberg
versammelt sondern sich besser verteilt
das ist natürlich marginal aber das ist
es eben das problem wie kontrolliere ich
diese zuflüsse wie schaffe ich ist dass
die menschen sich eben vernünftig
verteilen draußen und nicht alle auf das
gleiche ziel zu stürmen da habe ich im
augenblick auch noch keine passende idee
da ist halt wieder die
eigenverantwortung der menschen gefragt
und da bin ich tatsächlich in der
längeren zeit in der wir uns in der
pandemie befinden manchmal an zweifeln
ob die eigenverantwortung da tatsächlich
voll umfänglich ausreicht ist es mit der
eigenen verantwortung ein großes problem
man hat mir ja so ein bisschen das
gefühl gehabt die bürgermeister die sich
geärgert haben dass ihr ort überrannt
worden ist versteht man zwar einer
andererseits hat das aber etwas
genannten haften ton wie kommen diese
leute jetzt her und wagen es bei in
unseren wäldern spazieren zu gehen
unseren roten zu gehen fiel das so ein
bisschen auch die das
einfühlungsvermögen der politik für die
bedürfnisse sind manche menschen
das fehlt es häufig sag ich mal bei
diesen überfallartigen besuchen auf
bergen zum rodeln und so kann ich wieder
ein bisschen verstehen das ist ja so
eine art folk situation mit der man
jetzt gar nicht gerechnet hat vor allem
weil man über flashmob also los weil man
ja vor allem aus vernunftsgründen gar
nicht damit gerechnet hat also wenn wenn
ich zu so einem berg fahren würde und
ich würde sie nicht kriegt ja schon gar
kein parkplatz mehr weil es einfach
alles voll ist dann würde ich vermutlich
nein ich würde ganz sicher nicht
vermutlich würde ganz sicher daran
vorbeifahren und dort nicht zum rodeln
gehen was die eigenverantwortung
betrifft würde ich gerne noch mal auf
hinwiese komme ich finde es unheimlich
wichtig was er gesagt hat zu den schuhen
und der eigenverantwortung
da sehen wir dass politiker was bremsen
können sie haben einfach da die besseren
ideen sie haben die bessere erfahrung
sie können das besser machen und werden
dann doch angewiesen es so nicht zu tun
da glaube ich muss sich die politik
wirklich einen großen ruck geben und
diese eigenverantwortung der schulen
überhaupt zu überlassen wir haben das ja
auch von anderen schulen zum beispiel
aus solingen gehört wo die schüler für
den wechsel unterricht in hybrid
unterricht geworben haben und und das
machen wollten die stadt auch noch dafür
aber dann vom land gebremst wurde das
sind alles dinge die sind die sind über
lehrer oder fühlen sich ihre kollegen
ganz deutschland dagegen dass kinder
glaube ich hygiene konzepte von den
bundesmitteln untersagt worden die die
schuljahr im vorhinein entwickeln
wollten um darauf auf alle möglichen
eventualitäten zu reagieren also ohne
zweifel also wenn man die stellungnahme
energiewesen kohler verbindet dann
stellt man fest
die kollegen fühlen sich an bestimmten
stellen gegängelt es gar keine frage
herr professor ich habe noch eine zudem
impfen weil das ja heute eine wichtige
rolle gespielt hat ja inzwischen ist ja
auch zum wahlkampfthema mutiert diese
diskussion geführt worden ist müssen wir
das alles auf der europäischen ebene
machen und müssen nicht erst mal an uns
denken die anderen haben jetzt die
impfstoffe die wir eigentlich bräuchten
das zimmer der immer durch die
berichterstattung so durch befürchten
sie da wieder
eine renationalisierung von impfstoff
politik dass in zukunft die gesagt je
nachdem wie lange die pandemie noch
dauert und vielleicht auch eine neue
kommt dass man dann wieder jeder sich
erstmal an sich selbst denkt und dass
dann das ja eigentlich dem europäischen
gedanken auch ziemlich abträglich ist
also ich hoffe nicht dass das passiert
das wäre ja aus meiner sicht
wirtschaftlich sehr dumm wenn man sich
gegenseitig konkurrenz macht statt als
einkaufsgenossenschaft aufzutreten
im prinzip ist das ja eine blendende
idee dass man das ebenfalls mit einer
großen nachfrage macht macht und und
koordiniert macht und als einheit
auftritt
es müsste dann eben auch nur effizient
sein und da kann man vielleicht einige
abläufe noch optimieren kann er sagen
dass das sondern kabinett am morgen
zusammen die bundeskanzlerin mit dem
wirtschafts mit dem finanzminister mit
dem gesundheitsminister und dem
kanzleramtsminister jetzt das alles an
sich zieht und auch die umfrage zur
chefin sache macht ja das ist eindeutig
so dass muss auch besser geregelt werden
das ist das was wir auch vorhin
angesprochen haben dass man aus fehlern
lernen kann und so sind auf mehreren
ebenen die dinge nicht gut gelaufen und
aneinander vorbei geplant worden und
wenn es da jetzt noch mal so einen ruck
gibt und ist von der kanzlerin moderiert
und von den ganzen fachleuten zusammen
im kabinett beraten wird das ist
sicherlich eine konsequenz daraus und
das ist dann ja auch richtig so das
heißt also das ist tatsächlich da nicht
als wahlkampfthema taugen liebt ist ich
glaube das werden sie morgen doch noch
mal besprechen dass sie das tunlichst
vermeiden sondern weil das vertrauen der
bevölkerung in die politik ist sehr auf
den putz auf den prüfstand gestellt und
die politik muss sich sehr sehr erdung
kümmern dass alle das so noch mitmachen
können ich finde dass die politik großes
leistet in vielen bereichen und das ist
in teilen oder wir alle vielleicht auch
noch auf hohem niveau jammern und
insofern bis sie sich alle vielleicht
ein bisschen zurücknehmen und mehr
zusammenreißen aber das bemühen da ist
aus dieser krise zu kommen das land
davor zu bewahren dass der wohlstand
einbricht und dass wir fälle haben
werden wo patienten auf
intensivstationen nicht mehr behandeln
und die todeszahl wächst das würde ich
ihnen nicht absprechen und da ist das
denn dann haben sie uns ja noch jetzt
ein versöhnliches ende in der sendung
bereitet haben so weit ich bedanke mich
bei ihnen kristina dunz robert kiesel
professor andreas radbruch und martin
stürmer für die diskussion liebe
zuschauer
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit mal und
am ural
und auch da geht es um das thema
lockdown was da heute beschlossen worden
ist und die diskussion wer hat was
falsch gemacht beim impfen oder
vielleicht doch nicht
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]